[Musik]
[Applaus]
150 metern in eine menschengruppe unter
ihnen auch eine schulklasse aus hessen
eine lehrerin kommt dabei ums leben und
unter den vielen zum teil schwer
verletzt noch eine schwangere frau mit
gebrochener hüfte bei dem unmittelbar
nach der tat festgenommenen mutmaßlichen
täter soll es sich um einen 29 jahre
alten in berlin lebende deutsch arminia
handeln hier sehen wir ihnen mit einer
decke verhüllt ago h ist sein name er
ist einschlägig bekannt wegen
eigentumsdelikten nach bild
informationen fanden die ermittler in
dem auto so hat es die zuständige
innensenator in gesagte plakate die mit
einem türkei bezug
versehen waren also nicht ganz klar wie
das einzuordnen ist möglicherweise also
ein politischer hintergrund auf keinen
fall ein unfall ein amokläufer ein
eiskalter killer so hieß es aus
ermittlerkreisen zu bild wir haben
diesen furchtbaren tag in berlin für sie
zusammengefasst
szenen der verwüstung in berlin vor der
gedächtniskirche am beliebten
breitscheidplatz knien einsatzkräfte der
polizei und feuerwehr am boden und
versorgen verletzte ein silberner
kleinwagen steckt im schaufenster eines
geschäft gegen 10.30 war der fahrer
genau dieses renault clio in eine
menschenmenge gerast eine person kommt
dabei ums leben mehrere menschen werden
verletzt teilweise schwer wie es zu dem
unfall kam ist zunächst völlig unklar
ein augenzeuge die straße auf die ich
jetzt zeige von da drüben kam das
fahrzeug geriet dann auf den gehweg dann
kurz auf die straße dann wieder auf den
gehweg und hier direkt vor mir über
einen passanten dann kam es wieder auf
die straße und dann da hinten dann
nochmal auf den gehweg und dann voll
durch eine menschenmasse
ein stück weiter runter
dieses video zeigt eine der ersten
aufnahmen des tatfahrzeugs der wagen
steckt in einem schaufenster auf dem
gehweg vor dem geschäft ein schwer
verletzter mann passanten versuchen ihm
zu helfen
verwirrung panik der gehweg eine
schneise der zerstörung
noch sind keine rettungskräfte am tatort
nur wenige meter weiter überall dort wo
der fahrer entlang gefahren ist schwer
verletzte menschen
der fahrzeugführer konnte von passanten
festgehalten werden und dann unmittelbar
von einsatzkräften festgenommen werden
aktuell wird er zum
sachverhalt befragt wer steht natürlich
auch unter dem eindruck der geschehnisse
wir müssen jetzt halt wie gesagt schauen
inwieweit als sich meine vorsatz tat
handelte oder um ein verkehrsunfall
setzen jetzt das was klassische
ermittlungsarbeit ist das mosaik
zusammen aus vielen kleinen stein dieses
video zeigt aufnahmen der verhaftung des
mutmaßlichen täters der mann im gelben
hemd wird von einem polizisten abgeführt
es ist zu hören wir um hilfe bittet ein
anderer mann im hintergrund antwortet
was hilfe du hast fast zwei umgebracht
du idiot der fahrer wird schließlich dem
haftrichter vorgeführt die ermittlungen
zum unfall dauern an war es ein
verkehrsunfall ein medizinischer notfall
oder möglicherweise sogar eine geplante
tat mehrere schwer bewaffnete
polizeibeamte sichern die umgebung
gegen 13 uhr gibt die polizei
informationen zum festgenommenen bekannt
wie bei den verdächtigen kann ich bisher
nur gefallen dass es sich um einen 29
jährigen mann handelt
und das ist tatsächlich der aktuellen
erkenntnisstand den ich dazu habe
inwieweit er jetzt tatsächlich verletzt
wo er selber verletzt wurde oder unter
dem einfluss des ereignisses stehen das
kann ich noch nicht sagen grundsätzlich
ist es aber so wir haben ihnen unsere
obhut und wir werden ihn zu dem
sachverhalt findig
[Musik]
mittlerweile ist bekannt die tote ist
eine lehrerin aus hessen die mit ihrer
schulklasse in berlin zu besuch war
zwölf schüler werden verletzt einer
schwer
einmal
habe ich bis zum gipfel
dann war ich für den menschen die haube
gezielt auch die menge menschen mit
vollgas richtung in meine richtung und
dann habe ich weggesprungen hennes &
mauritz und es war nicht schreckliche
will dann muss man sagen und ja es war
echt nicht schön anzusehen
erstmals war gedacht dass ich zum glück
fünf minuten später kam nachdem es
passiert ist das genauso gut auf mich
erwischen können und ich hätte der auf
der straße dienen können und es da denkt
man schon mal drüber nach
am nachmittag macht sich die regierende
bürgermeisterin franziska giffey ein
bild der lage
wir sind erschüttert darüber dass
es zu einem vorfall gekommen ist der in
uns allen schlimme erinnerungen weckt
auch
an den anschlag vom breitscheidplatz
ich möchte zuallererst einmal mein
tiefes mitgefühl für die opfer zum
ausdruck bringen für die betroffenen für
ihre angehörigen ein richtiges
bekennerschreiben gibt es nicht es ist
richtig wir werden jetzt das auto
entsprechend natürlich untersuchen das
läuft gerade es sollen plakate wohl drin
liegen aber
bekennerschreiben an sich gibt es nicht
da muss man sehr vorsichtig mit jetzigen
äußerungen seien
augenzeugen bestätigen die vermutung
dass es sich bei der tat nicht um einen
unfall gehandelt hat
das war 100 prozent das war absicht
listung des vorgangs das war als ich und
ich habe
das gemacht weil ich habe gesehen eine
frau in diese komplett runter der konnte
gar nicht atmen die contec-x atmen ich
habe sie gerade gemacht und ich habe
gesehen dass die augen ist zu konnte gar
nicht so wäre gesäubert gehen und ich
konnte gar nichts mehr atmen und ich
habe gerade ich habe hier geguckt die
schon gereicht schon fast nicht ein
minute ist schon fertig ein sommertag in
berlin wird zum alptraum für eine ganze
stadt
[Musik]
okay
wir sind verbunden mit christian matzka
verheißt der kriminalist an der
hochschule für wirtschaft und recht in
berlin hermsdorf nach all dem was wir
bislang wissen offenbar schriftstücke
gefunden worden vielleicht plakate dort
im auto mit einem wie auch immer
gearteten türkei bezug das hat die in
senatorin von berlin heute gesagt und
dann wissen wir es handle sich um einen
deutsch armenier
29 jahre alt
ihre einschätzung womit haben wir es
hier zu tun
nach dem jetzigen stand der dinge nach
den informationen die jetzt auch
öffentlich gemacht worden sind müssen
wir davon ausgehen dass es sich um eine
tat handelt die geplant war wo ein täter
in kauf genommen hat oder sogar
gewünscht hat dass menschen ums leben
kommen schwer verletzt werden um einen
hohen aufmerksamkeitswert zu erzielen
das ist das was wir jetzt wissen nach
dem stand der veröffentlichen
informationen
wir müssen allerdings noch nicht was die
vernehmungen die bis die ersten
vernehmung durch die kriminalpolizei
ergeben haben das heißt wir sind noch
angewiesen auf das was ermittelt wird
was der täter vielleicht zu seiner
eigenen motivlage ihr noch aussagen wird
und das ist das was uns natürlich
brennend interessiert was über zurzeit
aus nachvollziehbaren gründen eben nicht
medienöffentlich gemacht werden kann
weil die ermittlungen laufen und wenn
wir überlegen der vorfall ist erst
einige stunden hier und wir sind schon
was den kenntnisstand angeht sehr weit
aber eben noch nicht umfassend
informiert
nun wird in diesem moment der
mutmaßliche täter in einem krankenhaus
untersucht ist das ganz normal also wie
es geht und man sich nicht um äußere
verletzungen wir haben videos gesehen
heute da ist ja ganz normal abgeführt
worden
natürlich ist er gleichzeitig auch in
diesem wagen gewesen ist in das
schaufenster rhein gerast hat eben
mehrere menschen auch umgefahrene oder
handelt es sich hier um eine ganz
normale und zwingende sozusagen auch
psychiatrische untersuchung was würden
sie sagen
also ich gehe davon aus dass in erster
linie festgestellt werden muss wie weit
dieser mann verbrachte ich und
möglicherweise hofft fähig sein wird
werden ja davon ausgehen können dass der
mann dem bereitschaftsstaatsanwalt der
staatsanwaltschaft vorgeführt wird und
durch ein ermittlungsrichter oder der
richterin dann entsprechend einen
haftbefehl hält allein wegen der schwere
der tat hier schon ein zwingender grund
nach dem jetzigen stand der dinge ich
gehe davon aus dass die haftfähigkeit
festgestellt wird ob auch weitere
untersuchung stattfinden das auch man
sich jetzt schon um die psychische
zustand dieses menschen kümmert oder ob
es vielleicht nach der festnahme oder im
zusammenhang mit der festnahme dinge gab
die es zwingend notwendig gemacht haben
diesen mann ins krankenhaus zu bringen
uns sowohl körperlich wie auch psychisch
zu untersuchen das können wir zurzeit
nicht sagen ich denke dass schon dass es
in erster linie um die haftfähigkeit
geht
nach ihren erfahrungen wann macht es
klick so zu sagen wann dreht dreht etwas
durch bei einem menschen dass er sicher
auch traut so eine tat zu begehen das
ist ja eine hemmschwelle auch die man
überschreiten muss innen menschen hinein
zu fahren was kann sowas auslösen
ich würde antwortet dieser frage gerne
psychologen an meine seite stellen und
auch kriminologen die sich gerade mit
den verhältnissen von cezanne opfern und
von den prozessen des täter werden es
hier eben darüber sehr gut informiert
sind und entsprechende auskünfte geben
können wir können aber immer nur den
individuellen menschen die
persönlichkeit des menschen immer nur an
den konkreten einzelfall dann beurteilen
wir wissen nicht was sich bei ihm
ergeben hat die wissen ja nicht einmal
ob es eine vortat phase in einer
planungsphase gab möglicherweise es kann
durchaus sein dass diese tat relativ
kurzfristig spontan als
kurzschlussreaktion eben dann so
umgesetzt worden ist das können wir
zurzeit noch nicht sagen und wir wissen
auch nicht in welcher fassung sich
dieser mensch befindet was sein ganz
persönlicher hintergrund also
beispielsweise der hintergrund seines
persönlichen sozialen umfeldes wie der
sich gestaltet das können wir nicht
sagen wir das beurteilen können dann
haben wir ein gesamtbild und können auch
die ersten thesen ausstellen aufstellen
wann dann zu welcher zeit kann der tat
entschluss gefasst worden ist oder aber
dieser mann wird es den ermittlern und
ermittlerinnen mitteilen weil er
vielleicht doch etwas manifestieren
möchte das frustrierende vor allem für
die opfer ist ja dass man bei solchen
taten dann immer über den täter redet
und nicht über die opfer diejenigen die
natürlich leiden darunter wir
analysieren solche täter sie tun das als
kriminalist aber letztendlich lehren
kann man ja nicht daraus ziehen um taten
in zukunft zu verhindern wir sehen ja
dass wir hilflos ausgeliefert sind
also ich würde nicht unterschreiben dass
wir hilflos ausgeliefert sind wir können
allerdings tatsächlich dieses risiko
eben nicht komplett ausschließen also
eine risiko besteht wenn man sich einen
öffentlichen raum begeht dann geht man
sich tatsächlich in eine zone die mit
verschiedenen risiken belastet ist das
ist ein teil wenn es um die indikatoren
geht also wie kündigt sich so etwas an
das gibt dir aus dem marmor geschehen
heraus immer diesem begriff des
lieblings also der vorankündigung durch
möglicherweise kleine detaillierte
informationen durch besondere
auffälligkeiten im verhalten das ist
eine möglichkeit um in einzelfällen dann
entsprechend aufmerksam zu werden auf
potenzielle täter aber dazu gehört auch
dass jemand da ist der signale
wahrnehmen kann und wenn er sich in
einem feld bewegt was die signale
entweder ich wahrnehmen kann konnte oder
nicht willens die signale wahr zu nehmen
dann gibt es auch keine möglichkeiten
sozusagen früh waren aspekte indikatoren
hier festzuschreiben die möglicherweise
eine solche tat verhindert hätten wir
sollen jetzt die opfer damit umgehen und
wie sollen auch ja jeder von uns damit
umgehen wohl wissend dass auch wir dort
hätten zu diesem zeitpunkt sein können
wir können aber nicht in ständiger angst
leben
ja diese frage die ist natürlich aus
kriminalistischer sicht schwer zu
beantworten kommunisten gemäß den
versuchen in ihrem vorgehen opfer nicht
sekundär tertiär zu kritisieren das
heißt dass beispielsweise durch
vernehmungssituation von zeugen opfer
noch mal in eine situation gebracht wenn
diese möglicherweise dann noch weiter
traumatisiert noch weiter schädigt aber
was den das allgemeine leben öffentlich
nach oben an da müssen wir tatsächlich
der expertise aus ganz verschiedenen
richtungen zusammenziehen um dazu
aussagen machen zu können eine
verunsicherung also eine allgemeine
verunsicherung der gesellschaft
beispielsweise die darf es nicht geben
denn dann hätten diese täter und diese
täterin das erreicht was sie erreichen
wollen und wir müssen dem entgegentreten
wir haben keine angst
das ist ja mal vielen dank
das gespräch haben wir kurz vor dieser
sendung geführt fassen wir noch mal
zusammen was im moment bekannt ist also
am breitscheidplatz in
berlin-charlottenburg mitten in berlin
da wo der ku'damm ist da wo das kadewe
ist da wo die gedächtniskirche ist und
eben der breitscheidplatz wo es schon
einmal einen anschlag gegeben hat 2016
dort ist heute morgen eine amokfahrt
abgelaufenen eine frau ist tot eine
lehrerin einer schulklasse aus
nordhessen eine schule aus bad arolsen
eine ganze klasse war dort die lehrerin
ist tote zwölf schüler sind verletzt
insgesamt waren 24 schüler dabei sie
wollten einfach einen ausflug machen in
berlin das wetter war wunderbar dort wo
tausende menschen sich aufhalten morgens
und den ganzen tag über berliner und
eben auch touristen der fahrer fuhr
einfach durch die menge durch ging von
der stadt vom bürgersteig herunter
wieder auf die straße wieder auf den
bürgersteig und landete schließlich in
einer parfümerie die polizei war mit 130
einsatzkräften vor ort passanten
überwältigten den unfallfahrer
schließlich 29 jahre alt sein name ist
kein deutsch armenier aus berlin
polizeibekannt wegen
eigentumsdelikten und wir schauen auf
das video das zeigt wie
die ersten aufnahmen des tatfahrzeuges
wir sehen gleich den renault clio den
sie wollen auch schon hinter mir hier
gesehen haben das silberne fahrzeug das
der täter mutmaßliche täter von st
schwester haben soll wir sehen hier wie
die passanten auf der straße da haben
wir das auto im schaufenster kurz
gesehen und der passanten versuchen noch
den verletzten dort zu helfen viele auf
der straße und
fassungslosigkeit in diese momente da
sehen wir das auto weit in diesem mann
schaufenster drin und wir sehen auch
aufnahmen vom tatort
vor wenigen stunden haben sie uns
erreicht wir haben auch übrigens gesehen
wie spezielle terror ermittler dass in
visier vom lka berlin dort vor ort im
einsatz waren diese so genannten quick
identification teams also die teams zu
schnellen identifikation wurden
aufgebaut um nach einem anschlag noch am
tatort tatverdächtige so schnell wie
möglich zu identifizieren das ist hier
ja auch gelungen die beamten das sehen
wir hier tragen helme und schusswesten
offenbar suchen sie am tatort auch nach
dna und fingerabdrücke des
tatverdächtigen
den ganzen tag vor ort ist auch unsere
kollegin unser reporter hannes rafik zu
dem wir jetzt schalten kannst du stehst
dort noch am breitscheidplatz man sieht
hinter dir die gedächtniskirche nehmen
uns mit beschreibt uns die situation was
du dort den ganzen tag über erlebt hat
und wie es jetzt momentan aussieht
dazu gab es gerade gesagt mahngericht
meistens in solchen fällen über die
täter ich möchte einmal über das opfer
sprechen das todesopfer die lehrerin die
mit ihrer schulklasse in ihrem kollegen
einen schönen tag in berlin verbringen
wollte hinter diesen blauen zelten war
sie eben zusammen mit dem zehntklässler
aus hessen ihren kindern mit ihren
schulkindern die sie jetzt bis zum
abschluss gebracht hat wollte sie eben
noch einen schönen tag in der hauptstadt
verbringen und ist dann jäh von diesem
auto erfasst worden die uns während der
letzten verletzung direkt hier frau
auferlegen es ist wirklich grauenhaft
wenn man sich das vorstellt dass diese
jungen menschen mit ansehen mussten wie
ihr vorbild wie ihre lehrerin wie sie
begleitet hat hier zu tode gekommen ist
und die ermittler des lka haben jetzt
hier eben zelte aufgebaut wo sie dann
aber aktive spuren sichern und wenn es
eben zu einem prozess kommt eben dem
täter dann auch entsprechende vorhalten
machen zu können und nichts dem zufall
zu überlassen wir haben eine
polizeikette gerade gesehen die hier
noch einmal abgesucht hat die die
inhalte von mülleimern nochmal
extrahiert hat und gesichert hat das
auch da eventuell im spuren eben nicht
verloren gehen und wir können einmal her
übergehen noch auf die andere
straßenseite das ist die rankestraße die
wehr zu überqueren hier war als wir also
heute vormittag her gekommen sind war
eine verletztensammelstelle von der
feuerwehr eingerichtet worden die auf
diesem teil des bürgersteigs wurde neben
die zahlreichen menschen die von dem
auto erfasst worden sind und umgerissen
worden sind direkt von der feuerwehr
versorgt und dann von hier in die
krankenhäuser gebracht und wir haben aus
einem gastronom der hier in einem
restaurant gearbeitet hat eben wirklich
gehört anschaulich welche draußen im
biergarten saß und ein seltsames
geräusch gehört hat sich umgedreht hat
und dann die menschen uns liegen gesehen
hat der hat gesagt er hat gar nicht erst
verstanden was da passiert aber es hin
gerannt und hat dann schreiende menschen
auf dem boden liegen sehen an eine junge
schülerin die wir am bein verletzte hat
der erste hilfe geleistet ist dann
weiter in richtung praktischsten ziehen
da wo dieses auto weiter gerast ist
diese schneise ist er hinterher gelaufen
hat dann eine eine person gesehen die am
bauch stark geblutet hat hat auch diese
versorgt und war danach selber extrem
angefasst und und verstört weil er mir
erzählt dass er auch damals 2016 einen
terroranschlag hier am breitscheidplatz
auch dabei war und diese bilder kamen
natürlich wieder hoch bei ihm und er war
wirklich richtig angefasst konnte jetzt
auch nicht weiter arbeiten ist nach
hause gegangen und hat sich ausgeruht
von diesen schrecklichen tag hier mitten
in berlin der city west
es ist alles abgesperrt im moment wird
es dabei zunächst auch erstmal bleiben
weiß ich ja mit ladenbesitzern
gesprochen oder angestellten die in den
geschäften arbeiten am zaun ziehen und
an dem stück eben vom kurfürstendamm
noch ist alles abgesperrt sind natürlich
keine passanten die auf den straßen auch
der fahrzeugverkehr selbstverständlich
auf den straßen und das wird wohl noch
so bleiben die ermittlungen laufen eben
noch das ist ebenso eine schwere tat
dass die kriminalpolizei alles auf was
sie hat um wirklich jede spur eben zu
sichern bleibt nichts dem zufall
überlassen und die leute die ich
gesprochen habe die hier arbeiten haben
gesagt dass sie von ihren chefs gehört
haben dass morgen eben die läden hier
auch noch zu bleiben und bis auf
weiteres geschlossen werden und die
polizei denn irgendwann den tatort
freigibt hannes grafik vielen dank diese
reportage und beginnt weiter zu unserer
kolleginnen annika rage die auch den
ganzen tag vor ort ist dort schon annika
und du hast auch mit augenzeugen
gesprochen heute
genau zuerst haben wir heute morgen kurz
eben nach dieser tat mit dem
polizeisprecher thilo kablitz gesprochen
da hat er uns gesagt wir müssen erst mal
dieses mosaik zusammensetzen um uns
darüber im klaren zu werden was hier
überhaupt passiert ist und genau das
passiert jetzt rund acht stunden nachdem
das eben alles passiert ist hier vor ort
hinter mir seht ihr den übergang von der
vom kurfürstendamm in die
tauentzienstraße vor dem nie weiß wo es
eben heute zu dieser tat gekommen ist
hinter mir seht ihr die weiße plane die
immer noch als sichtschutz gilt dahinter
lag eben die lehrerin die heute morgen
ums leben gekommen ist
durch diesen durch diese durch diese
fahrt und dann schwenken wir nochmal
weiter nach links wir sehen von hier aus
nicht mehr ganz so viel weil hier würde
es nämlich jetzt sehr weiträumig
abgesperrt weil jetzt damit gerechnet
wird dass dieses auto das dort hinten
eben 200 meter weiter in den douglas
gerast ist und eben nicht jeder dabei
zuschauen soll vor diesem douglas steht
auch immer noch ein roter tribus ich
hätte von den busfahrern gesprochen der
durfte eben nicht mehr an seine sachen
die in dem bus immer noch hat durfte
auch diesen bus nicht wegfahren also es
wird wirklich weiträumig hier gerade
ermittelt ich habe auch noch einige
polizeibeamter gesehen die eben noch in
mülleimer hier geschaut haben also es
wird wirklich jeder mm hier genauestens
untersucht damit man eben genau
nachvollziehen kann was genau passiert
ist war ja eine merkwürdige geradezu
gespenstische situation heute zu sehen
einerseits eben diese furchtbaren bilder
andererseits hat man auch gesehen wie
viele das offenbar gar nicht richtig
realisiert haben und auch einfach
weitergingen das hat ja auch er
augenzeuge mit dem du gesprochen hast
gesagt
genau der augenzeuge mit dem ich
gesprochen habe war ende 20 hat sich
hier eben auch in der gedächtniskirche
aufgehalten wie viele andere augenzeugen
die dort betreut wurden von
notfallseelsorgern und er hat mir auch
gesagt ich war total verwundert denn am
anfang sind ganz viele leute erst mal
stehen geblieben oder normal
weitergegangen haben sich überhaupt gar
nicht um die verletzten gekümmert die am
boden lagen weil sie gar nicht die
situation einschätzen konnten und das
ist eben auch so heute scheint die sonne
wir haben kurz nach pfingsten viele
menschen gehen eben gerne über den
kudamm jetzt viele touristen sind in der
stadt gehen über den kudamm gehen
shoppen man kann eben nicht mit so etwas
rechnen und da braucht eben der
menschliche sind auch ein paar minuten
ein paar sekunden um überhaupt zu
begreifen was da gerade passiert ist und
eben auch erst zu helfen was dann
glücklicherweise viele menschen sehr
schnell getan haben eine garage vielen
dank für diese eindrücke die du uns
schildert den ganzen tag über vor ort
gewesen